and today is the day that we earn the
name legends
now
hey everybody this is gonna be my
legends of tomorrow finale video I'll
talk a little bit about season 4 because
they basically already told us who's
gonna be the main cast members
Constantine is gonna be coming on the
show but we don't know about Wally so
there's still a lot of questions so be
sure to subscribe if you're just finding
me for the first time the flash is also
back tomorrow so brand new flash episode
coming starting with number 10 so in the
wake of last week's episode they need to
buy time so they go to salvation Jonah
Hex is time in place because it's like a
blind spot they kind of set that up last
season there were a couple twists from
last season that they paid off this
season especially Aruba which I can't
remember they may have teed that up way
back in season 1 because at the end of
last season heatwave was the only one to
go to Aruba but this time everybody went
so that was just them paying off the
Aruba from last year number 9 though rip
hunter sacrifices himself with the time
bomb big question is is we don't know if
he has gone from the show completely the
way they play it so fast and loose with
time travel which is a lot like the way
doctor who plays with time travel like
there are rules but they break the rules
all the time
so if Doctor Who is allowed to get away
with stuff like that is probably okay if
legends of tomorrow brings him back and
it's like how did you get here as long
as the logic of how he comes back at
least works a little bit it'll be
totally fine you could kind of tell
through the episode that there were a
lot of character turns meant to help
cycle the roster so like you could see
Amaya was like slowly moving past her
relationship with Nate the way she was
accepting her responsibility for what
she done changing the past but as for
rip hunter it's not like he's a
character on another TV show so it's
always possible that he comes back in
some form or another in the future like
there's so many ways beyond death to
bring characters back number 8 Jonah Hex
is back always awesome to see him on the
show like he's not that big of a
character and they didn't give him that
much to do during the episode but now he
has this ship going on Lazzari I guess
there's some connection between them but
anybody that's alive at the end of the
episode is fair game to come back so I
think it's gonna continue to be the same
situation with his character like who to
show up once per season for some fun
storyline we might not always go back to
salvation because they have to go to
this set to physically shoot here but
you could always grab him and bring him
into present-day or wherever they might
need him so he could continue to get
started no matter where
they decided to go but I am a big fan of
Western so I did love the way they work
in the good the bad and the ugly theme
like the title of the episode was the
good the bad and the cuddly finally
found out what the cuddly part of that
meant - like the bebo twist at the end
don't know how you felt about that I'll
talk about that later like in a separate
point just because of the whole Voltron
theme like the producer specifically
said that they tried to make the right
mixture of ridiculousness silliness and
like a really good payoff for all these
characters storylines so I felt like
they actually did a really good job with
that but the stuff that they were doing
this season with the Mallis character
and the stuff that they were paying off
just allowed them to have a little bit
more fun with this finale which is why
if you like it a little bit better
that's probably why because there are
certain rules when you use characters
like the reverse-flash
you know what his powers are you know a
lot about his character so it's harder
for them to use him in a ridiculous way
and for it to feel believable than it is
for them to use this crazy time demon
concept who isn't a character from the
comics it's just like somebody fun that
they created for the show this sort of
leads in to their season for demon
supernatural Ark so number seven Rey has
his crazy plan to go back and save Nora
this feels like where they were heading
with the character all season long like
they were gonna save Nora one way or
another and I didn't expect damian
darhk-- to be on the show next season
anyway so they've effectively killed him
off but I think the idea at the end of
the episode is is that because they use
all six totems including the death totem
they're able to defeat him permanently
so there's no way for him to come back
meaning that this version of damian
darhk-- also probably got taken with him
so if we see damian darhk-- again tooth
and it'll probably be some other version
of the character or it'll be some memory
if they bring the Nora character back
number six was the way they turned
Mallis into a joke to take the piss out
of him they called him phallus they made
fun of how to pronounce his name is it
malice is it malice so they did a good
job of foreshadowing how ridiculous the
ending was going to be number five was
the High Noon reference with all the
armies marching into town that we've
seen on the show so far basically every
evil big group that they fought is back
the Romans the Vikings the Pirates there
were a couple things that I didn't like
about the way they used those characters
but there was a speech that Sarah gave
they sort of tied it all together and
made it work being so ridiculous Sarah
does her version of the Independence Day
speech today we declare
our independence day today we earned the
title legends and that you know it's a
totally awful cheesy speech but then the
thing that makes it all work and brings
it all together is when she just adds
that little bit at the end and says now
we need to find a way to sneak out the
back which i think is an overlooked but
very important part of writing this TV
show like the characters can swing from
one end of the personality spectrum to
the other like Sarah goes from thinking
she's complete trash to being really
high on herself like I can do this I'm
super awesome but you have to sort of
tag scenes like that with moments of
self-awareness so they did a good job of
that but number four the first time that
they try to create their Voltron baby I
love the Cronenberg II and nightmare
that came out of it too and heat wave
just narrating the whole thing are we
making a baby because there's been so
much speculation about a baby coming to
the flash TV show eventually all I could
think about when heatwave was saying
that were flash jokes like this somehow
is meta referencing all the stuff that's
happening on the flash this season but
then Ava rides in and you have Helen of
Troy firestorm and kuwasa who has become
the new vixen in this alternate timeline
they created when they saved her village
speaking of change my number three was a
mile leaving at the end I felt like a
lot of people wondered if she was gonna
be the person to leave because they
focused so heavily on her arc this
season her trying to save her village
like be the person that she knew she had
to be but also having all this fun with
the legends shirking her
responsibilities with Nate like it was a
big plot point at the beginning of the
season that they not have sex on
missions their relationship couldn't
exist it was forbidden love and they
said you know what screw that we're
gonna do what we want to do which as you
know is like the worst possible way to
act when you're a superhero so at some
point she was always gonna go back to
Zambezi in because like the big main arc
of the season was tied to the totems it
really was a vixen season of legends of
tomorrow in next season is all about
demons demonology the supernatural
aspects of the DC Universe so it totally
makes sense that you're swapping her
character for Constantine in represents
a big shift in the mythology of the show
the thing about her going back to 1942
though is that because they don't wipe
her mind presumably now she'll still
have memory of what needs to happen in
1992 so she'll know about the attack
when it's getting ready to happen
able to save her village again and
preserve the new alternate timeline
where kuwasa became vixen who they
actually gave the totems to at the end
of the episode just hang on to these for
safekeeping until people come along
bitter worthy to wield them the other
thing about the end of the episode - is
that Rey slipped Nora dark that time
stone I don't know if that's meant to
have been deactivated like I don't know
if there's still power in that and she
can actually go back in time to save her
father but I think the idea is that
she's gonna be chilling in time prison
until they want to bring her back on the
TV show so it's like you know you put a
character like Roy in another city
speaking of which Roy is now a season
regular on arrow season 7 we have to
talk about that in the separate video
but like well Roy was not on arrow
he was just off in a separate city like
st. Roke where he was in Bludhaven
hiding out until they wanted to use him
in an arrow episode so he'd show up and
say hey what are you been doing this
whole time so it'll be the same thing
with Nora if they ever want to bring her
back same thing with vixen - like if
they ever need to go back to 1942 to
join her for a mission they can always
do that but we got to talk about number
two the Voltron bibo baby that they make
so for the most part people in my
Twitter timeline we're down with it but
I have a feeling it'll be one of those
situations where you're either on board
with it because it's so ridiculous or
you hate it because you didn't like the
Bebo stuff to begin with earlier this
season but like I said as crazy as it
was it was more authentic to the tone of
the show than the season 2 ending for a
brief minute though I forgot that it was
all the legends inside the actual
Voltron bibo so I was like wait a minute
how come the Bebo can do bits because it
started doing comedy bits while they
were in the middle of their fight it
made a Bruce Lee kung fu joke and when
it took mullahs down the cloud that
exploded was a heart shape so it was
almost like they were killing Mallis
with love but number one of course was
that end tag with Constantine showing up
whose good idea was it to release a time
demon so basically if you've ever
watched a single episode of Supernatural
usually what happens is is that either
demons go rogue or demons escape from
Hell or things from alternate realities
escaped into our reality it's just very
rooted in magic in mythology so because
Constantine is going to be the series
regular now you kind of see what their
mission is they have the time bureau to
deal with the anachronism
but they will be dealing with all these
demons that they'll probably be hunting
down so think of it as like the
supernatural version of a DC show with
them playing Pokemon with all these
demons got to catch them all I don't
know which comic book characters they're
gonna be able to use sometimes it's wide
open sometimes certain people who are
off-limits so we might get to see some
more magic based characters from DC
Comics but like I said Constantine
series regular next season we don't know
if wall-e is gonna be coming back to
legends of tomorrow because he's a flash
character so I think it just depends on
how they're gonna use him during flash
season five like Colton Haynes is coming
on to arrow they're supposed to be some
big cliffhanger big change in the status
quo Stephen Amell says we're gonna do
something that we can never take back so
he is really hyping up what their season
7 is gonna be like but just let me know
what you thought of the episode and
what'll happen is is I have some Titans
news we got to talk about Roy a little
bit more and there'll be flash video
tomorrow because there's a new episode
so leave all your reactions in the
comments below
but click here for brand new infinity
war and click here for a brand new flash
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
you